for people who are still depressed after
Red Sox water serious loss and not in
yet and this thing will lift your spirit
and we figure we need something new so
this is called join the translation on
your science seminar series almost like
a water series so and so this first time
I can head in the morning so it's a
great and this is the kickoff so I'm
very very happy that we have John Jay
berry and to kick off this new series
this is supported by purchase center and
the Stanley Center and jointly with mdh
and cat and Jim porches are here and
thank you for coming and today our first
week for this series is junk everywhere
you probably all know very well is the
investigate an amalgam Institute also
the Grover Herman professor of Health
Science and Technology also the
professor BCS and our department and
he's also the director of material
imaging center MIT is also the director
on the integrated learning initiative at
MIT I don't know how there's all these
things I only do once in my lab and
still running like crazy dog and John
before doing a my team 2005 he was at a
math professor Stanford for 14 years and
soon so he helped me win many many
awards and he was also elected to an
american academy of art science in 2004
16 and this year johnson research is the
folks that actually and human cognitive
aspect of the real human brain like many
of us we take easy we're going to study
animals he actually really study humans
and he mostly use brain imaging method
you were probably him today he's a
pioneer and a world leader in imaging
approaches study human memory and and
the language and really in human object
and his research examined the function
and dysfunction of of the human memories
in normal object in normal human
functions and also in disease including
Alzheimer disease and Parkinson's
disease and dyslexia and ADHD so you
probably hear some of them just today
and he also is studies he also studied
the changes of governmental changes how
the structure and function change during
development affected mental ability in
children and most recently he has been
pioneering something which we think is
really really exciting we all know for
most of brain disorders and especially
mental illness we don't have biomarkers
and clinical trial often fail not
necessary because of bad draga target a
lot of times we just don't have a way to
measure the muta for depression you ask
how do you feel in the last three weeks
so it's a very hard and science for
clinical trial without biomax and john
has been doing some really exciting work
to use imaging approaches and
non-invasively can look at how this
mental state change how the drug can
affect weather can we use these yummy d
approached you to predict if FX e are
targeting engagement of objects if that
if this works they would really change
the way how we use the bio marks not
only for diagnosis in the future for
predict for FX a prediction of even
clinical trials so without further ado
yeah thank you gunning for that a very
kind introduction it's an honor to
participate in the series and in the
research behind the series and I'm going
to talk today about the predictive
neuroimaging and precision medicine for
neuropsychiatric treatments I'll tell
you what that means a little bit but my
entire career I've been fascinated as a
scientist and concerned as a person who
worries about disorders about the
fragile power of the human brain so we
know the brain empowers every human
capacity of thought a feeling of action
in the world but for every strength it
has it empowers in humans it has an
Achilles heel or a vulnerability if
we're able to think we're able to have
thought disorders such as in
schizophrenia if we're able to have
feelings we can have a effectiveness
disorders like depression or anxiety if
we're able to be brilliant and invent
print
by which spoken language becomes visible
over time and space I had my broken
glasses incident from childcare
yesterday sir it from from time and
space you know then we also have brains
of individual children who struggle to
learn how to read in dyslexia so this
balance between the awesome power that
were trying to decode on the one hand
and remarkable vulnerability on the
other is the essence of understanding
the human brain and for many years our
knowledge was fueled by injuries brain
lesions to interpret bring differences
but that many things are hard to address
that way but now we have additional
tools with lots of limitations but lots
of power as well with functional and
structural neuroimaging non-invasive
imaging of the human mind and brain so
today I'm going to tell you about four
groups of studies where we want to ask
this question where might we translate
the knowledge that we're gaining about
the human brain and his disorders into
something that's actionable and helpful
for patients and families what is that
bridge going to look like and so one
bridge I'm going to suggest is something
about early identification not waiting
until children or adolescents are in
crisis and are the victims of their
difficulties and things are accumulative
but rather early identifying somebody at
risk and preventing or diminishing the
severity of the disorder at all and I'll
show you a little bit of work we have
that's more promising than the natural
treatment and then second and graphing
touched on this can we use brain imaging
to predict things about individuals that
are not currently predictable by
clinical and behavioral measures can we
predict the fate over the next several
years of a child struggling to learn to
read can we predict among patients who
responds for example to form a treatment
in this case cognitive behavioral
therapy and the more we can identify for
an individual patient whether particular
treatment will be helpful we think the
more we can steer people too helpful
treatments right from the start now I
think that the kind of basic research
that happens in the McGovern Institute
and broad and elsewhere that's a kind of
research and animals that will its
translation to humans that will be the
home run game changers right entirely
new approaches to
we know that we need much better
treatment so we have now but you can win
a lot of baseball games Red Sox could
have used a few more singles and doubles
right you can make people's lives a lot
better I think with knowing which
treatment is optimal for which person
now among available treatments and I
will come and tell you in a few moments
that how shockingly random it is now
which patient gets which treatment so
when I think of infants born into this
world around the planet I think of them
as all participants in a neuro
developmental lottery they will be born
with jeans and born into environments
that we more or less supportive for
their flourishing and development and we
know that many children face
difficulties about ten percent of
children struggle to read dyslexia about
ten percent struggle to pay attention in
the way that we demand they pay
attention and this is always a fit
between what our society or educational
system demands and the brain and mind of
a child so before we event in print
there was no such thing as dyslexia
right because it was in the brains but
it didn't matter for a person's life
before we ask that people sit in rooms
like this starting in pre-kindergarten
and going all the way through to a
marital status as I'm working on now
silently in big groups pretending to pay
attention at least we didn't demand the
kind of a focused sustained attention
that we now demand an education for a
child to move forward and succeed in the
classroom so ADHD is also partly a
consequence of the educational societal
system we live in we also know that
poverty has a big issue in terms of
brain and development we also know that
there's a risks for many mental health
difficulties let me switch now for a
moment to reading so my colleagues who
study language development whether it
being linguistics or cycling lists
xterra one mission is to say how is it
that the child or the infant
miraculously acquires language it
shouldn't happen the parent doesn't have
a handbook the infant as a handbook I
don't have a handbook and yet in
languages throughout the world in
countless situations infants brilliantly
acquire the language of their caregiver
that kind of spontaneous a
predisposition to brilliance and
language is kind of the opposite of
learning to read learning to read is the
first boot camp that every child
encounters in pre-kindergarten for
in second grade as students teachers and
parents worry about whether the child
gets basic reading skills which are
really the Avenue by which all education
happens after that so people in
education of the slogan you first you
learn to read and then you read to learn
okay and without that reading almost
everything in education becomes
difficult and yet something like about
the numbers very about ten percent of
children really struggle to read now we
know something about the psychological
causes of this and like it any complex
difficulty there are many different
causes that play out differently in
different children but the most common
and best understood cause of reading
difficulty or dyslexia works like this
when a child learns to read in an
alphabetic language like English um they
know objects in the world they know like
a book and a scarf and they hear their
parents say the words book and scarf and
that's and they go to school and then
kind of like shocking news about Santa
Claus the Easter Bunny and the Tooth
Fairy I think everybody in this room is
beyond that I worry sometimes when I
talk to audiences with parents and
children are kind of like that shocking
a teacher says no you know you thought
that book or scarf was kind of like one
big glob e word you know actually the
Sikh there's a secret we haven't told
you it's actually composed of individual
sound elements those individual sound
elements or like are what's called
phonemes so book has bit incur okay and
you need to know that because those are
the sound elements that will map on to
the strokes of black and white on the
printed page you need to know that this
sound goes with this uh this sound goes
with this letter in order to decode
written words on a printed page you need
to know the sound units and that
awareness that words are composed of
sounds of unit that can be mapped on to
things or taken apart or pull together
has been called a phonological awareness
and so learning to read is largely
mapping these fun emic units of sound in
spoken language on to the units of print
on the page and up until the early 1980s
people had thought the primary primary
problem in dyslexia was visual and they
thought that because the most
common cases were these the child is
speaking satisfactorily at home with the
caretaker goes to school and all the
sudden struggles to read and everybody
assumed it was the at you no experience
with print the visual experience that
was a big roadblock the big problem
because spoken language seemed fine
comprehension seemed fine but studies in
the 1980s going forward showed that the
most common difficulty for children who
struggle to read is actually a weakness
in this ability to pull apart the sound
units of spoken language into their
units it's a problem in high-level
processing it's not basic hearing
high-level processing of sound units
there are other things that influence
reading development but this is the best
understood this is our delightful a mock
scanner used downstairs to make children
comfortable in practice going MRI this
is a note from a participant a
particularly enthusiastic one where she
wrote when she came in this is her
drawing of a noisy scanner and she
writes to the graduate student you have
let me have a more fun in three days and
I could have in any other place just
think of it I'm playing a game when at
the same time I'm a research guinea pig
if you're a harsh grader you take up a
couple points for spelling but maybe you
don't and who knows that one of the same
time I met someone else my age and if
they have great problems while still
earning money a tiny bit of money goes
you know to the parent but here's the
beautiful sentiment what do you think
beats at nothing right okay that's
practically the motto for those of us
who work in this field which is like to
see us a little bit of a grant on a
salary and then we want to help people
and nothing beats that right okay but
this is expressed completely beautifully
by this child so in a study some years
ago now at Stanford with least temple or
less pulled rock and others we looked at
10 year olds who were either typically
reading or who had trouble reading and
dyslexia they came in and we did
functional MRI with the brain function
and we compared their brains as it's
activated by two different conditions in
one conditions they would see pairs of
letters like these they decided to the
same or different you don't even have to
know what they represent states are
visually similar or different that's our
control condition the comparison
condition we're interested in is we show
them pairs of letters like these and for
each pair they have to think about the
sound associated with that letter name
so they have to say do they rhyme so G
and K and in different sounds those
don't Ryan but T&D and in that a sound
they rhyme okay so they're making these
judgments about sound and what we found
and what's been replicated many times
since this is functional MRI top bottom
left and right through three consecutive
slices up the brain and typically
developing children and activation sort
of near Broca's area so order near
wording CBC areas you move up as these
children think about the sounds
associated with the letters compared to
merely looking at the letters look at
the absence of activation back here in
children with dyslexia and this
misplaced one in the frontal region very
striking differences in how the brains
are processing this most basic
information these are 10 year olds
they've done a fair bit of reading okay
but that is such a brain difference in
terms of how the print is related to
sound and this core findings has been
replicated many times these are a few of
many many studies that have found
reduced response in this area of the
brain around the left hemisphere around
the parietal and temporal area as
children or adults try to think about
what sounds are associated with print um
and we did also did a study in many ways
was a limited study but more about you
know better subsequent studies have
replicated the same result from the side
the activation of thinking about the
sounds of letters from a typical child
the paucity of activation reduced
activation in the children with dyslexia
and after they undergo an intervention
the growth of that activation here so
when we originally did this we thought
wow this is exactly what we think
educational support ought to be about
sort of somehow making available a
neural pathway that's typically
available that's not available to some
children for some reason but that the
right educational intervention can help
them use that pathway that was not
available now this is the left
hemisphere that I focused on because
that's the hemisphere associated with
reading and language primarily but we
also had big changes in the right
hemisphere and we for we have to say
something so we called this
normalization because this activation
looked more like typical readers and
there's this huge growth of activation
the right hemisphere which i'll come
back to we call the compensation just to
have a label for it that doesn't explain
anything it's just uh I said this makes
it look more like
typical readers and this is an
unexpected boost of activation in the
right hemisphere now we've also been
investigating brain differs it's and
children who struggle to reducing
diffusion tensor imaging or DTI it
visualizes white matter connectivity in
the brain indirectly by measuring
microbe micron level movement of water
in the brain so here's a cartoon neuron
here's the axon that's transmitting
information out of the neuron here's a
myelin sheath that surrounds that exon
if it goes any distance to make the
signals go rapidly and accurately if
you're a drop of water floating around
in the brain you can go anywhere you
want if you're something like cerebral
spinal fluid but if you're approaching
these myelinated axons which travel in
bundles as tracts you can't go through
it you have to go around it and that's
the sort of indirect way that we
estimate properties of white matter
connectivity in the brain and so you can
derive pictures like these let's see if
i give this sorry about this working
this morning not going to work nampa
still um he would just spin around and
basically showing you that the fiber
tracts that are running up and down in
blue back and forward and green and left
and right in red and so some years ago
around 2000 torkoal klingberg and i
looked in adults and we found white
matter differences in adults with a
history of reading difficulty in about
the same region that we saw the
functional MRI differences the methods
at that time were very limited but it's
lists as we could estimate it it was a
pathway that ran forward and backward in
the left hemisphere around here with the
biggest difference here and if we looked
at the individual data and this is a
very small number of participants we
wouldn't do such a small number now this
is the measure of white matter property
this is how the readings corner
standardized reading test the black
circles are the poor readers the open
circles are the good readers typically
developing readers and so we were we
were you know struck by that we couldn't
tell though whether this is a
consequence or a cause of the reading
difficulty so one interpretation is that
chunk and this is this will be the right
one I think that uh
there's a difference in brain
architecture for some reason that we
don't have some genetic reason probably
maybe mixed in with environmental
factors and that makes somebody be a
better reader or a worse sweeter all
right so that's one possibility and so
this person who had the highest score
you know they were lucky with the genes
and rookie with the environment that
made them awesome readers so that's the
causal story and these children were
unlucky as they grew into adults the
consequent story is exactly the opposite
which is this is the brain is muscle you
know metaphor maybe everything's about
even in all these individuals but maybe
this person was the kind of person who
on the bus home read war and peace and
second grade okay the reading reading
reading reading reading they love it
they can't you can't stop and so just
like any kind of skill or practice
changes the brain through experience
maybe all that reading altered the white
matter architecture of the brain and
maybe these individuals who struggle to
read do a lot less reading in effect
they do and so they just don't have that
change so is it the cause or the
consequence and merrily about 15 years
later we have a hint that it's the cause
and this is a study in collaboration
with Liz Elizabeth Norton here and
Nadine gab Children's Hospital will be
screened approximately 1500
kindergarteners and about 20 diverse
schools in the Boston area brought in
about a hundred eighty for more detailed
testing and we fund then we're following
these children now the critical thing is
we're doing the imaging at the beginning
of kindergarten before they get formal
reading instruction in Massachusetts it
starts at around Thanksgiving so we're
looked of course they had experience
with text at home but in terms of school
they have not yet received formal
education about how to read so we know
there's not a lot of reading experience
and there's no reading instruction and
then we looked in these children and we
focused on the arcuate fasciculus that's
the white matter bundle that connects
Wernicke's area and Broca's area the
sort of core language areas of the brain
and we looked at a few other areas as
well and I'll tell you in a moment that
way we've found is this if we looked at
tests of phonological awareness that are
they have to be spoken tests these
children mostly don't know how to read
so we might you might the test of it
might be something like this they might
say listen to the word clip
if I take out the cur what's left okay
and with any luck Issei lip that would
be example of being able to manipulate
the sound languages the sounds of
language and what we found is so that as
we looked at the different properties of
white matter this way we found it it
correlated quite strongly with their
reading the ability to make the sound
judgments about language and this is
before any reading instruction and my
colleague nating gab has now shown that
if for infants born to a family with the
history of reading difficulty she can
see in the same track differences within
a month of birth so we think this is a
beginning point for some of the
difficulty that goes with learning to
read and so here's somewhere now
tracking these children through first
and second grade and here's an example
of one child who has a poor phonological
awareness was be and by the end of 1st
grade is well behind her collar appears
in reading here's a child with a
different wet matter sighs and
architecture who had good phonological
awareness at the beginning of
kindergarten and by the end of 1st grade
has a good reading score so what we're
seeing we think is the beginnings of
what will make learning to read easy or
difficult and what we would like to
imagine is that now you could do some
sort of intervention in a kid
pre-kindergarten child before he or she
ever fails not wait until they're one or
two or three grades behind in reading
level but do a different kind of
educational support for them even before
they fall behind their peers so this
this is a we both won't understand neuro
biologically was different in a child
who struggles to read but also we think
has implications for educational policy
and practices as to how to help children
succeed and not fall behind their peers
um we turn to depression for a moment in
childhood and as much as there's been
fantastic progress in many aspects of
research regarding the brain basis of
depression the reality is that there's
still a huge struggle to help children
in the rate that we would want to so
here are statistics about the increase
in suicide which is the obviously the
most tragic failure of mental health in
adolescence three-fold increase in girls
with 10 to 14
over the last 30 years so it's one
marker of how important and difficult
the challenges of supporting on mental
health in adolescence this is a
statistic of that kind now there's been
many studies looking at differences
between adults and also some with
children who do not have depression
there's many studies like that but again
we sent have the same problems of the
cause or the consequence if we're aiming
to move towards early identification and
prevention when we see brain differences
for depression and a twenty-year-old of
30 year old a 40 year old are those
brain differences the reason they got to
be rip depressed or vulnerable to
depression or are they the manifestation
of depression itself and we can't pull
those things apart so one research
strategy to understand whether brain
differences men are about the cause or
the consequence of depression is to look
at children born to a parent with
depression a child born to a parent with
depression has a three to five fold
increased likelihood of developing
depression that means many won't but
there's an increased probability they
will and so and in our study that I
about to describe to you all of the
children had at least one parent with
diagnosed depression on but none of the
children were depress themselves but
they're all 8 to 14 and about 15 out is
the age when depression most often not
always but most often begins to express
itself in larger numbers so we're
looking at an age range where depression
is sometimes but rarely manifested but
it's coming up in these children the
high-risk period and so in this study we
looked with Jenny chai and Joe Peterman
we looked at children who are at risk
but had no current depression and with
one parent then we had children who
heard the comparison group who were
matched in most ways but they had no
parental history of depression so was
nobody's depressed clinically but some
children are family risk and some are
not and while they're in the scanner
what we're showing them is pictures like
these where they're mashing up whether
these faces the same or not there are
negative fearful expressions or happy
expressions neutral expressions or
objects and I'll just summarize the
results of the study this way that
showed for the children who
or at risk who had a parent with
depression were increased
epidemiological risk their brains had a
decreased response to happy face at an
increased response of negative faces
okay so if you think about the cognitive
bias ideas of depression that part of
what leads to depression is a focus on
the negative then a sort of disinterest
or non response to the positive that's
exactly what we saw the children at risk
although they were debt not themselves
depressed their brains were more
responsive to negative facial
expressions and less responsive to
positive facial expressions exactly what
you don't want in somebody you know
focus on the negative and that sort of
disinterest or lack of response to the
positive um we also looked at two things
I just mentioned them very briefly
diffusion tensor imaging which I told
you about to look at white matter
connectivity and then resting-state
functional connectivity the era is a
functional MRI measure we're looking at
naturally or spontaneously occurring
fluctuations and brain responses or the
fMRI signal while the child is there
doing nothing okay there's no task we're
just looking spontaneous relations
between regions and without going to
detail I was just say that we found
multiple differences both more active it
more connectivity and less connectivity
including involved a sub general
anterior cingulate cortex which is for
the hot spot for depression research on
in these two groups and the thing I want
to leave you with this to last thoughts
on this topic one things we're really
interested in and i'll move to this in a
minute is when can brain measures tell
us things above and beyond clinical
information that's now available on and
so one of the questions we asked is this
if we use a clinical rating scale that's
widely used the child behavioral
checklist is widely used in pediatric
psychiatry how much how well can we
differentiate the children who are born
at risk versus nahai and if we look at
our functional imaging differences how
well can doze tell us apart okay so
because in the end we're not going to
look my look at children who are just
born to families with a history we want
to look at all children
who's at risk and where we might
intervene early to avoid stark
depression and what we found was that if
we look at the cbcl rating a clinical
checklist that's you know the kindest y
leaves in research this was our accuracy
64 percent but with the brain we were
able to better differentiate the two
groups now we have a lot to go on that
because you know we don't know who will
depress depression who will not but this
is one hint where the brain measure
seemed more sensitive to risk than a
typical checklist and the last thing
I'll tell you about this is just very
briefly as we also looked at white
matter a development across the ages in
these same children and found something
striking that's a cross-sectional study
we're looking at each child at a certain
age we need to do longitudinal ones but
cross-sectionally we found that we look
in some of the white matter around the
anterior cingulate we see an increase in
this property of white matter that
typically increases in development in
the control children and a starkly
different reduction of the signal and
the children who are at risk as they
approach the very age where their
highest risk for starting to develop
depression so we see a very different
developmental trajectory in these
children in the organization of this
white matter as well so there's a lot of
different ways in which i think we're
betting get signals about who's it more
at risk and understanding maybe who what
with whom we ought to intervene and
maybe even having an immediate measure
whether the intervention is working
around so now let me turn a little bit
to treatment so most neuroimaging
studies including the ones I showed you
today are basically sort of correlations
of one kind or another between
differences in brain signals between
groups like patients with or without
depression people with whether were the
oppression conditions like showing faces
versus words or something about
behavioral performance in the scanner
that's what most of us do all the time
but I'm really interesting in terms of a
clinical thinking about clinical
challenges and helping people are we at
a moment where brain measures tell us
something room you know powerfully more
than current behavioral and clinical
measures and this is always a you have
to do this with one hand ready to erase
because tomorrow somebody can have a
better clinical measure or behavioral
measures it's not like the field is
going to stop but it's just where we are
now and so the left when I want to lead
in the last
the talk is basically can we use
prediction I'll use it a couple
different ways as a humanitarian and
pragmatic contribution from human
cognitive neuroscience so when you talk
about prediction on the internet they
have funny debates about who said this
prediction is very difficult especially
about the future they're depending on
which source you see it's either niels
bohr or robert peterson or Mark Twain or
I like Soren Kierkegaard thing life can
only be understood backwards but it must
be lived forwards all right so in a
certain way that also there is also
going to show you our backwards because
we know the outcomes then we're going to
look back at the brain all right and we
in the long run we need to run the other
way we need to look at a child or a
person and say oh you're at risk we
should help you or oh you would respond
better to this treatment than that
treatment right we could but at the
moment we're still doing this so when
should one example from dyslexia and one
from social anxiety disorder now I'm a
huge fan and participated in the
community of human cognitive
neuroscience so we learn a ton about
functional and structural architecture
of the human brain how it varies across
people and cultures how it varies a
neuro development and neuropsychiatric
disorders but we have one huge challenge
I think in our shoulder which is to my
knowledge and I'll make this case in a
moment then maybe I'll get beaten back
we've made nobody's life better no
patient or family or clinician who wants
to help a person is better off right now
based on everything we know from
functional or structural human neural
imaging it's kind of a shocking thing
I'll come back to this and try to defend
it and then so um so I'm interested in
what kinds of brain measures might be
different than that can then for example
better predict long-term outcomes can
they better predict individuality
variance from patient to patient
response to a treatment so here's an
amazing thing um if you go into PubMed
and you put in a diagnosis like
schizophrenia and MRI you come back with
almost 6,000 published papers in PubMed
right or depression or anxiety or autism
or ADHD or dyslexia or obsessive
compulsive disorder you add those up
your about 20,000 and that's not
including EEG you know erps positron
emission tomography diffusion tensor
imaging necessary okay so 20,000
publications and yet when dsm-5
out in 2013 not one diagnosis not one
discussion of treatment has been
influenced by anything we've done in
brain imaging so far on and it only
makes me feel better I'm a huge fan of
course with the amazing genetics you
know all over the world but it brought
outstandingly I don't think genetics has
done any better yet is that okay no I
like it's like you're the drowning
person you want to pull somebody with
you let's pull down the genetics yeah
but you seriously you know really you
know there's you know we're surrounded
by the world's outstanding hospitals
here and nobody is diagnosing or
treating I believe any brain difference
or learning difference fundamentally
different based on anything we know
about brain or genetics um so so you
know so I think that's and so their
challenge I think in part is to say what
could be I finding then in the
foreseeable future could touch the lives
of people you know a short of some
amusing meteor discovery that changes
the world okay and we thought that could
happen but what could be and so I was
going to tell you about the direction
that I'm thinking and other people are
as well and let me just say one method
ething for a moment um usually and I
showed you some correlations earlier
people will correlate things like for
example a brain signal versus the
outcome of the clinical treatment most
of those are what people kindly call
overly optimistic that is any given
correlation you get is inherently
unlikely to be replicable the same
strength for a new pot group of
participants it's just the way things
work typically so decor analyses I shall
you now aim to be one step better than
that which is using methods that on
purpose seek generalization and
individuation that is for example
leave-one-out cross-validation in which
each person's outcome is predicted on
the basis of the activations or the
brain signals from the other
participants in the study because if
we're ever to apply these things you
know to help patients it can't be it has
to be for a single patient and has to be
in the moment that they're choosing what
course of treatment to get right so so
we're very interested in these questions
about how to how to how to make these
kinds of predictions better
and I'll say two things about these
neuro prediction measures that are
different than we normally do in studies
with patients with a mental health
differences first most studies look at
similarities among patients if you
compare a group of patients with
schizophrenia or bipolar disorder
depression to typically developing
individuals for example you're
interested in what's the most similar
thing about each group that you can pull
them apart and the studies i'm about to
show you we're interested in the
opposite we're interested in
heterogeneity among patients because
it's a heterogeneity we want to
understand as it comes to for example to
the clinical course or responsive
treatment so it's exactly the opposite
we want understand diversity not
similarity within a diagnosis and the
second is we're not really studying
anymore brain differences that go with a
disorder I think we're really studying
the brain's capacity to heal that is if
we're studying response to treatment or
progress in an area we're not
necessarily studying the reason why a
person as a difficulty we're studying
the brain mechanisms available to them
to get better and those things will be
somewhat related but we do they're often
not identical at all right so I think
that's a kind of almost a newish field
in brain imaging which to say let's
identify the neural mechanisms in the
brain that are available to help a
person get better on so let me start
with dyslexia and then I'll talk about
social anxiety so we know some children
with dyslexia have made considerable
progress and some don't what's the brain
basis of that can we tell who's going to
progress in who won't so in the study
with Fumiko heft we have somewhat older
children around error average inch 13c
pairs of words like bait engage and ask
if they rhyme to make it a little tough
for them we make them look visually
different so they have to sound out the
word again and so that's how we're
looking at phonological processing in
the brain and 25 children with dyslexia
20 typically reading children we do the
brain imaging functional MRI diffusion
tensor imaging and we give them 17
behavioral measures IQ reading and
language that are widely used in
clinical and educational research and
then we see them two and a half years
later in a longitudinal design and see
how they're doing in terms of reading
and here's what we find so here's a
single word reading score 100 is a
population average here's our controls
out you could say what kind of public
school system is not moving these
children to be any better readers in two
and a half years but it's okay it's not
a critique of education because it
scores our age adjusted okay so that so
these children are reading well for
their age and they remain reading well
for the rage here are the children with
dyslexia reading poorly but one groups
make some progress and what groups to
mix no progress relative to the rage
that single word reading which was our
identified outcome measure but if we
look at comprehension for our paragraphs
which is the ultimate goal of reading
not getting a word correct at a time but
get grasping the essence of a paragraph
you can see these same children to make
some progress on single word
identification make a lot of progress
I'm grasping what's in a paragraph and
these children make very little so we
have two subtypes if you will of
children with dyslexia those who make
substantial progress and those who don't
now they're doing this task prepared
deciding whether words rhyme or don't
and we have a big surprise for us which
is the part of the brain that was the
best predictor of which child would be
in the group that makes major progress
versus not is activation in the right
frontal cortex each dot here's an
individual child with poor reading and
read the more they improved on reading
over the years the more was the response
in right prefrontal cortex as they
judged where the pairs of words rhyme or
didn't Ryan I'll come back to that in a
moment I'll just say here without going
to detail that we also found similar
structural differences in right
prefrontal cortex using diffusion tensor
imaging so that makes a bit more
confidence there was a you know both
functional and structural right
prefrontal cortex now why is that weird
it's weird because one thing we know
about learning to read in typical
development is as children begin to read
they're pretty bilateral leaves both
hemispheres to begin to deal with print
because as you're beginning reader print
is a visual spatial puzzle is it a B or
addy if you've had a little kid recently
you've been reading with it's like it's
like the hardest question you can get a
presidential debate is it a beauty with
purity I was a guy like there's no way
to know ya BA ok Nick teased and apps
and all the kinds of stuff they're very
difficult visuospatial problems and the
right hemisphere is dominant for visual
spatial processing and it's very
bilateral but as children get better at
reading a few grades later a few years
later almost all the processing
letters we've been on print becomes left
hemisphere dependent because that's the
way it enters the left hemisphere
language system and a fluent reader
directly relates to print on the page to
the language they know okay so so weeks
that's left word another thing is
several studies have shown that as
children become more fluent readers
early on they activate both frontal and
posterior areas but it's become better
readers it tends to move posteriorly and
that's because that frees up the frontal
cortex to do things like thinking
inference and so on because now you have
a rapid automated system from mapping
what you see on to hear on to sort of
language systems so so we see most of
simple processing a print moving left
word and back and yet for those who
improve the most to moved rightward and
forward and furthermore if we did a
multi voxel pattern analysis that form a
machine learning to try to distinguish
which group a child belong and the ones
who improved or not we got the server
random set of voxels we usually get
which we don't know what they mean that
she's looking all the voxels and some
huge machine learning data-driven way
including some and right prefrontal
cortex but in other places so I'll
summarize the study here um here's a key
thing none of the 17 behavioral measures
predicted with our child would improve
or not either than categorically are
continuously none and at first we
thought well we're bringing images we
don't know the education literature if
we went out there but i can tell you
we're talking to many clinicians and
looking at every journal we can look at
nobody can predict which ten-year-old
will make big progress in which will not
and our best predictors here we're at
ninety percent accuracy about and
knowing where their child is in the
group that will improve or won't improve
so there's two messages here that i
think that we think about from this or
three one of them is um when a child
gets a certain level of reading are they
better off on average trying to read
like other children left hemisphere
pathway or trying to read in a way
that's best for them given their brain
architecture and whatever task got them
there right prefrontal cortex right a
suggestion that that with the activation
i showed you earlier all this right
activation right hemisphere
in response to remediation might matter
a lot and might matter even more so we
always thought the point was to make
poor readers read like good readers but
maybe the point is to let poor readers
read the way that is best for them using
an entirely different brain pathway the
children who don't succeed at that are
the ones who do the worst and the second
if you told a mother gee don't worry and
we're far from this but not you know
hopefully not done decade don't worry
your child is as a ninety percent chance
I'll make up a number here a little bit
that he or she will make great progress
in the next few years in reading for
every mother like that or father like
that you would tell another parent oh
I'm sorry your child is in the group
that won't make progress but here's the
importantly those children should get a
different kind of intervention we
shouldn't sit back and wait as we do for
half the children to fail and then go oh
gee you know glad we helped some
couldn't help others those children
whose brains are different enough and in
ways that we can measure we should be
very aggressive in trying experimental
interventions that don't just wait for
failure but try a different approach for
the half that benefit from education as
it now operates great for the half that
don't something incredibly different is
needed not just waiting for failure to
play out over the years the last study
or set of studies i'll show you about
social anxiety disorder so when i talk
to my colleagues in psychiatry who i
collaborate with and I wonderful ones at
multiple institutions in the Boston area
and you ask them how do you decide which
medicine to give or how do you side for
a given disorder how do you decide on a
you know whether a person should also
get cognitive behavioral therapy the one
of my favorite answers is doctors choice
ok some people practice genetics in the
following way they say oh I ask if
anybody in your family has that disorder
if they liked a certain drug will give
you that one okay and that's not bad
maybe I mean but it just tells you how
physicians patients and families are
operating in complete darkness as to
which treatment is appropriate for which
individual on and a hint about how big a
problem that is is this this is a you
know the famous star d study from nih
looking at depression and what they
found is in four thousand patients the
first treatment they give one treatment
about half of a
the response then they try a second drug
and a third drug and a fourth drug by
the fourth drug seventy percent of that
response okay but people are dropping
out a lot from the whole study even
though the drug is made available to
them because they're dealing with life
for not moving forward whether it's the
treatment that didn't work they're
discouraged or the problems arise and so
on so here's another study comparing
drugs versus a for depression drugs
versus behavioral therapy and again
about this fifty percent response rate
in terms of effective therapy and that's
almost the number you see all the time
for any well supported treatment has
gone through FDA approval or things like
that about half of patients have a good
you know clinically useful response and
about half don't and nobody knows which
half you're in when you go into a
doctor's office looking crowd so um so
so in one sense you know sometimes we
have tough problems like how does the
brain work that's a tough problem he all
we have to do here is significantly
better than chance and we could provide
something useful to families and
clinicians right the bar is low now it's
not so low that if we have it's not so
low that if you only get like one or two
percentage points better you know and we
can republished it but it's not
practical so we have to move you know
but but it's low because now treatment
is randomly assigned so i'll tell you
the final study social anxiety disorder
and excessive and unreasonable fear of
social situations seven percent in a
given year chronic disabling disorder
this is severe social anxiety and to
give you a sense twice the rate of
unemployment versus other anxiety
disorders and depression because so much
of getting a job is about interacting
with a person this is not shyness this
is crippling a fear of interacting with
other people um treatments again
sometimes drugs sometimes behavioral
therapy about half of patients respond
to each no clue as to which patient is
going to be in the half the response to
any either going to these poor
predictions so in a study what we did is
we looked at fifty-one patients before
and after behavioral cognitive
behavioral treatment and asked whether
or how our measures would go and now we
have to be competitive so one measure of
the severity of this a clinical measures
that Leibowitz social anxieties
Elda correlated point 38 or accounts for
about sixteen percent of the variance so
severity the more severe disorder the
more you respond but we have to beat
that and that's considered so useless
that is even though researchers will
measure this no clinician will bother to
use this kind of information and I'll
just tell you two studies in the first
study we had individuals in the scanner
looking at baseline before they get the
treatment seeing faces that are negative
or neutral and scenes that are negative
or neutral the scenes were irrelevant
the faces were which makes sense for a
social disorder right or difficulty and
without going into great detail but i
can tell you activations in posterior
visual areas correlated quite strongly
far higher than the severity scale with
how much an individual patient benefited
clinically from the cognitive behavioral
therapy so there's a you know much
information there somehow about whether
patient is likely to respond strongly
moderately or weekly to this kind of
treatment and if we although we looked
at it mostly continuously just to
simplify the picture this is activation
for negative faces compared to neutral
faces in the half of patients who have
the most response and this and a half of
patients with the least response to the
cognitive behavioral therapy so there's
all kinds of things we can think about
that and need to learn about that but
we're way higher than the clinical
rating scale and the last thing I want
to tell you about very briefly put is
higher than that so we both looked at
diffusion tensor imaging as a matter of
as a measure of white matter
conductivity and functional connectivity
fMRI signals and we put those together
and the peel of those two things is that
they're really easy to give relatively
speaking across institutions and
scanners all you have to do is lay still
long enough for us to measure which is
not trivial for everybody but there's no
task involved it has task demands
there's no arguments about which
stimulator use you're just laying still
for two sets of scans and in this study
we looked at connectivity to the
amygdala a sort of a whole brain multi
voxel pattern analysis which is
data-driven we looked at the white
matter properties of the right inferior
longitudinal fasciculus the white matter
track that's closest to that part of the
brain that showed the activation
differences and the prior ski
I showed you here's an example of the
brain differences we saw in relation
tears that improvement in clinical
improvement here's a white matter
properties at the beginning of the
treatment and you can see that the more
they have a certain white matter
property the more they benefited from
the treatment so if we put our measures
together here's how much of the variance
we could predict by clinical severity on
a formally administer rating scale about
twelve percent of the variance in the
study here's how much we do if we add
that to diffusion tensor imaging now
we're moving up to that high here's how
much if we look at the resting state
measures plus the severity and here's
how much if we put it all together so
now we're counting over sixty percent of
the variance which i think is meaningful
so and the other threatening thing is
that all these sources of information at
least in this study were additive we
thought that could be redundant you know
you could be measuring the same thing
three different ways so you keep adding
them and you're not moving forward as we
measure these different properties of
the white matter and the resting state
have put them together with initial
severity you're now a sixty percent of
the variance and whether a patient
responds powerfully or responds
minimally to the treatment the range of
responses um so and if we sometimes
people want to say well for an
individual patient we need green light
red light you know don't tell me
something about forty percent of the
variance I need to tell as it you know
so we said okay let's make you know this
is always trouble when you draw a line
but let's make fifty percent improvement
on the alsace that's a sort of standard
one to say like you know do you improve
enough or not and with a logistic
regression with these brain measures and
the initial severity we're about
eighty-one percent accurate and knowing
whether individual patient is in the top
group in responding to the treatment or
the bottom group so we you know we think
we're in a range that is well above
chance and now this is just one study
whinnies replication and generalization
it needs a stronger models of single
patient outcomes and of course the
decision being faced by a family or a
patient or a clinician is not we're
giving a lot of information about one
treatment it's which treatment to pick
among alternative plausible treatments
and so we're terribly interested in that
was beautiful work coming out from Helen
mayberg going to Kali
for depression memory I'll just tell you
very briefly to show the differences in
the brain of positron emission
tomography scanning that identify
patients who responded especially well
to cbt versus especially well to a
medication so different courses of
treatment and we think you know a lot of
the future is going to be about that
which is to say not any treatment of
course you're going to help somebody but
which among plausible alternative
treatments is the most likely to help
somebody so I've showed you examples of
uh I've summarized in a review paper
published a year and a half ago or two
years ago almost now on about 70 studies
that with weaker data or stronger data
it varies a bit all predict things and
let me tell you about two of them so
prognosis for depression response to cbt
or medication for depression response to
medication anxiety response to the
cognitive behavioral therapy in
schizophrenia let me tell you the last
two and the bad thing about the last one
I'll tell you in one moment is that
that's the only one most of you'll
remember after the session here we go so
this is a really interesting study from
Martin Paulus which I wish there were
many replications of this attempted that
I'm not aware of oops have patients
coming out of a 28-day program for
methamphetamine dependence now 28-day
program is a fairly standard number for
inpatient treatment for substance
difficulties it turns out that number 28
there's theories around but no evidence
where that comes from why not 21 why not
35 there's a theory around that because
the military would only give 28-day
leaves for soldiers but there's no
evidence for any of that okay so so we
know that 28 days is probably too long
for some people and too short for others
right then so but Martin Paula showed is
that looking at 28 days if he did fMRI
on individuals as they came out of that
treatment and then tracked them for the
next year he could identify 37 to 40
whether they would or would not relapse
we need a lot more science on that but
if we could have you know much more
certainty whether a patient needs two
weeks four weeks six weeks eight weeks
on a scientific basis I think that would
be phenomenal improvement you know in
terms of how we approach treatment for
substance disorders this is the one
you'll remember and this needs a lot
more work also so this is um I study
where they did imaging us as parole
came out of prison and asked whether
they could predict who would be
rearrested for offending in the next
year and got results that were
considerably above demographics like age
in criminal history um there's some
debates about the precise methods and
what you know you certainly wouldn't
want to it's like science fiction right
they could they could predict decently
who would really arrested or not in the
next year and of course that's exactly
what you want to know in a parole
hearing is should somebody stay in jail
because they're a threat to society or
should somebody be released because
they're ready to go back to a life
that's productive in society and you
could say well we worry a lot about
getting that right and you would so
there's a lot of social you know the
more we get good at predicting people's
futures the more social and ethical
issues that are to think through about
how to handle that information
responsibly but uh but but let me tell
you one last study which I won't show
you data don't worry which is a study of
judges in Israel deciding parole that
was published them years ago and it
turns out a fairly significant factor
was at time of day your case was heard
if you were heard in the first half of
the morning or the first half of the
noon after lunch on first afternoon
after lunch you had a better chance of
being released on parole din the second
half of the morning or late afternoon
okay and the hypothesis is nobody knows
why the hypothesis is is that to make
this hard decision to allow somebody out
as a criminal offender from jail on
parole you need a lot of mental energy
because it's a tough call to let them
out first thing in the morning those of
you know this you know you had your
coffee you're ready to go you're
thinking hard you make the hard decision
second half of the morning you're fading
is that I hypothesis and you go put back
in jail too hard to figure out what it
was you have lunch you have a little bit
of mental energy again so I first half
of the afternoon more likely to decide
for parole second half of the afternoon
people are fading let's let the decider
parole so I'm just saying a ton of
decisions about people at so many places
in so many ways are made on the basis of
very arbitrary and poor information now
weather is what treatment they get or
parole decisions or things like that and
so if we could be somewhat more
scientific in understanding what's the
probability that given knowledge about a
person's Brenda it would benefit from a
particular treatment for example I think
we could do a lot for people as we wait
for dramatic
improvements in treatment what if we
could get much more accurate at sending
the right patient to the right treatment
now so I have terrific collaborators and
I'm very grateful for the support from
the portrait Center for apt affective
disorders research of the McGovern
Institute without that we couldn't have
done a ton of this work was incredibly
valuable as well support from the NIH
thank you very much yeah yeah so so so
we like to tell ourselves when we have a
good result on these predictions you
know the advantage of the brain is that
we pick up a advantage practically with
the disadvantage scientifically is that
we can't differentiate at all the
genetic pieces of the environmental
piece okay so they're both in the brain
obviously the genetic pat you know
predispositions and all the effect they
have the environment one has all of
that's in there we can't tell those
things apart so that might be good for
prediction because you get you have
estimates out of both the genetic and
environmental contributions right to a
person's brain in mind dad for knowing
you know what it's not what the pathway
is when we're so far from pathways no
but that would be you know that's the
direction lot of people want to look at
for example look more that the parents
to think about in two phenotypes that
way i think this intergenerational
research is taking off for the reason
you're describing and you know
personally i would love it you know if
we could at every time I give this talk
practically people say well you're all
what about the genetics why can't we use
that to help predict which person
benefits from which treatment and I
think it'd be cool to try that I know
there's a huge risk in that kind of
research you know without huge samples
and of course the issue is we're almost
the opposite of huge sample research
we're trying to think about way
which for individual person we can give
a decent probabilistic estimate as to
whether they're on a risk for depression
or dyslexia or will respond to a
treatment better or worse right so we're
trying yeah i think we be fantastically
exciting to have you know collaborative
things between McGovern and road or
other other institutions and other
researchers to see whether we could
maximize even more of a more of the
variance looking at the combination of
genetics and brain measuring I would
love to do that yeah well you know so I
think I think we've taken like two or
three steps in the right direction but
you know but so here's a weird thing for
it which is how slow science moves in
terms of helping people rights as f is a
brutal thing because even this thing
which is pretty simple current brain
measure current measures of brain
imaging we're not doing anything you
really current treatments nothing new
right nobody has to discover amazing
things in the laboratory or you know go
against the odds but to even have enough
research I think to justify influencing
treatment you know we it's hard to
imagine it would be less than ten years
which is because you need you know a big
study you need to do that or not you
need to probably ideally have patients
who you build a model out of and a
completely new set of patients to see
that it all works okay so it's you know
in that sense it's a little discouraging
how much work would need to be done and
that's assuming you got the grant on the
first outing I don't I H or something
like that and then you know even that
could be five to ten years so I'm you
know so at but I do think that a at the
same time there's so much promising
research happening in this way that if
we really give it a big push you know it
might be sooner but you know that's a
big pass to go yeah
it is it's a pretty big variant to this
is why clinicians often like pills
because they go like that's the pill you
know and when you talk to you to the
people who are very careful about cbt
restore the ones we work with they have
what they call manualized cpt that is
all the people who give it have lots of
training to give it the same way to
everybody so it's very controlled dennis
you get out in the community and this is
just real life you know there's no rules
about who gets sick cbt is so well
documented to be effective as effective
as the best medication for many things
obviously preparation in the moment of
psychosis you can't do cbt but if a
patient is you know in a moment when
they can respond to cbt every study
shows ice at least as effective as the
leading medication statistically alright
so it has a great scientific reputation
that's well-founded well you can't
control is how every community clinician
will say I do cpt because they all want
to say that because they're all
impressed by that but in a lot of them
is just it's it's just a slogan that's
vaguely in their treatment and you can't
control it it's not like the pills that
you hope our manufactured consistently
so so this is you know so I so on the
one hand some people will say well you
know cbts do some way because it can't
be you know on the other hand you know
if you have a child a ten-year-old was
at risk for depression I think some sort
of behavioral therapy is the only route
that we would feel comfortable and give
it a try at the moment okay and so you
know we just have to try our best but
you're right cbt as it diffuses out in
the community among clinicians who it
can be can a lot of it is not what
people meant but Aaron Beck and others
mean by carefully controlled and
operationalize cbt so it's a practical
problem of delivery yeah I'm sorry and
then after you have enough said yeah
yeah
yeah I completely with you and that's
that would be another piece of in my
mind of the sort of individuality
understanding more of those yeah I think
the more we understand that internal
dialogue and relationship between a
therapist and a patient you know we
might also make more progress in
understanding with it what it needs to
look like depending on the patient yeah
I completely with you yeah well so
here's what I think so so what the star
depression study showed is that by the
time you get to fourth medication
seventy percent of patients have a
positive response if you hang in there
through for treatment failures right so
if we could know up front doesn't matter
which medication is likely the work
statistically for an individual patient
maybe they don't have to go through you
know three treatment failures or two
treatment failures or even one treatment
failure right so we have lots of
examples where we know already that the
veer that some people respond more to
one than another we just don't know
which person it is upfront so they can
be an initially assigned the treatment
that's most likely to work for them so I
think if your non responder to cpt
probably that wasn't a good investment
or needs to be a different form of CBT
but rather than just you know send
people you know off the cliff into
treatment if we knew up front that
there's a really good chance of the
patient would benefit more from this
drug than that drug more or less from
CBT then you would you might rationally
pick the approach they take so I think
we'll get multiple treatments you could
just pick the best one on some
statistical informed scientific rational
basis that okay where you have complete
non-responders that also is interesting
because what happens to those now when
there's a new drug that's tried right
they'll just be in your sample they'll
be the non-responders but if p with
point 05 you're better than your
alternative treatment or placebo the
drug is approved so by know I by
identifying something about the brain
differences and people who don't respond
to any current available one then those
people should be studying separately
right otherwise they'll just always fill
in that bottom part of a clinical trial
or an educational intervention right the
children who are not improving on
reading you know people go about what we
do they didn't improve but no but we
should try something different with them
because what we now do in schools won't
work for them okay so by identifying in
some way the two people who don't
respond to anything you know the
grimmest group in that sense in the way
you describe it we also a chance to say
let's try completely different things
with them and not have them just go you
just have this group that's not
responding to one thing after another
hidden statistically in our total group
effect we're by the people who do
respond is that yeah so in some cases
it's just an alternative treatment in
some case this is a new research
question but with the right people you
know that twenty percent of people with
major depression who didn't respond to
anything you know those should have an
entirely different aggressive research
approach because otherwise why are we
sending them to treatments that are
highly unlikely to work with them is
that ok that's yeah yeah
there's got to be something different I
can tell you you know we had the 17
measures of all kinds of reading scores
we could not find any difference they
were equally severe at the outset in
general reading problems so we could not
identify anything anything behaviorally
that distinguish those who would improve
buzzers those who would not but I
completely agree with you you know that
that could just be that we don't have
the right Behavioral Analysis evening of
the items in the test we have or new
behavioral measures I mean there will
always be improvements and other
perspectives about what to look for so
it's not like we want to say you know
behavioral analysis sophisticated one as
you're describing is frozen now we
compare it to brain things because you
know maybe there'll be other shrewder
things and maybe at you know
scientifically go back and forth now we
have a group of children who won't
improve now we could explore in them
what pattern of errors do they have that
differentiates them you know so so I
think each time we discover a group of
children are not responding or adults
it's a new research question about
what's different about them and what
what then might help them yeah yeah yes
so uh so sadly this is the slowness of
research we're working on that but we
don't know that right I parents always
ask me the question you're asking like
you know like what's going on in that
part of the brain and how do we get
people to use it and we don't know I
guess is something like there's a yes I
have a guess this is not scientifically
supported that it might be a more of a
visual approach to reading than the NASA
sort of language sound one and that
might be more efficient for those
children because sometimes I talk to
children who adolescents who have
improved quite a bit and here's what
they tell me if they just get to scan
text they feel like they're sort of
doing okay but if they have to read out
loud they fall apart okay what is there
what does that mean that means the
typical connection between a print and
sound is so problematic for them but
they find a better alternative pathway
may be a bit like speed reading actually
um that's better for them and it can
help them right so yeah so something
like that might be right but we don't
know and we don't have any scientific
knowledge on that yeah you want to weigh
in on that one or discusses that
basically the music center part that was
robbed remember us and the first task
you showed it was a Ryan past so
certainly that would go along with
having to sound out this is gonna sound
yeah make a judgment I didn't follow
their miss one thing is to how you got
to the paragraphs was exactly they were
doing that was different but again if
there was some a matter of auditory
rehearsing to sell than recruiting right
on a lot of roads area makes a lot of
times it's something along that line and
I think the fact that these children who
got better got a little bit better at
reading single words accurately but a
lot better getting the gist of a
paragraph tells us that their strategy
is not about getting each word correctly
okay their strategy is something about
getting the words close enough and
paying a lot of attention maybe to
context and so on that lets them grasp
the gist of the paragraph and of course
if you get the gist of a paragraph
that's the most important thing
typically for for reading for learning
yes as a matter of what averages 12 to a
group so how efficient isn't
stereotypical as well as what gets
recruited so there was some work back
when I was following this more that we
recruit the right on a lot of a produce
area for harder like do well enough over
here but when needed we can recruit this
guy over to the groseclose's a little
bit slower to go across but when they
did so that was I can't quite grasp this
but let me sound the sound rehearse it
to myself or whatever there's the
concert or a strategy see were talking
yeah these are great speculations run
well-informed ones we just don't have
any traction on that but I think it's a
really interesting question